before it's too late as well if the
black rook comes across and cuts off the
white king's escape route
it's game over suddenly jordan with 25
seconds he needs to either run away with
his king or maybe go active with his own
rook uh just to start kind of the
counter-attack against black's king
maybe bring the rook across uh after
rook takes pawn running away with his
own king that is the key oh oh i don't
know about this move he's played he's
played his rook over but
this wins for black now and there we go
the evaluation bar okay not even that
he's trapped the white rook oh
let's go back to the players because
what a trick
the white rook is suddenly trapped it
has no squares to go to oh and she's
about to take the win we saw jordan kind
of cover his face for a second and there
we go do we have a result
one move
it all turns around and anish wins
and that is the third decided game
actually because we also have a carlson
win we also have a ding win but uh
this is this has been quite impressive
here so far from anish